hello and welcome to the first lecture
of the bioinformatics algorithms
when I started teaching bioinformatics
two decades ago one of the biggest
challenges was to connect with very
diverse audience I had to talk to
computer scientists and biologists to
physicists and biochemists to
mathematicians and statisticians the
challenge was how to keep computer
scientists forced while explaining
sometimes convoluted biological concepts
and likewise how to keep biologists
awake while explaining sometimes complex
algorithmic idea I hope that in this
class we have in equally diverse
audience and that's why I decided to
start from a very simple problem here's
the first problem in this class given a
string called text one cut it to a
string called text and I see that some
of you already thinking about clicking
this class because it's so trivial
please wait you might think that it's
trivial but billions of cells replicate
it right now in your body your genome
don't think so
in fact the trying to accomplish
incredibly complex task of replicating
genome just think about this you need to
unwind DNA two strands of DNA and
separate them you need to make sure that
there is enough free-floating
nucleotides so replication can complete
because if you start replication and you
have to stop in the middle because there
is no energy left you are dead
so we in this course we will learn about
this and many other challenges related
to replications in fact the replication
in human genome is so complex that
biologists still do not fully understand
how it's done
that's my we will focus on replication
of bacterial genomes that are thousand
times smaller the a genome is thousand
times smaller and that's why replicating
bacterial genome is a little bit easier
I'm not saying that it is trivial and in
fact right now there are billions of
bacterial cells trying to replicate
bacterial genomes inside you because the
number of bacterial cells inside you is
10 times larger than the number of your
own human cells
now since bacteria usually have circular
chromosomes I have to slightly change my
problem you know a new problem is given
a circular genome called text one copied
to a circular text 2 it's equally
trivial but it makes some slight changes
in the set up that we need to address
the circle genome doesn't have a start
and an end and that's my roughly 5
million nucleotides ecology no has a
choice on where to start replication in
this class we will try to figure out
where does it start because all equalise
cells on earth start replication in the
same region called origin of replication
so our first problem we're in a genome
does it all begin
and the only information that we have is
the genome itself ok so let's go ahead
and let's first try to answer the
question of what are the hidden messages
in the replication origin that help
ecology gnome to figure out where to
start and here's the first or should I
say is a suit already problem in this
course finding origin of replication
I'll give you general you have to give
me the location of origin of replication
in this region does problem make sense
yes you may be right or wrong the
and Lincoln who you are are you computer
scientist or biologist computer
scientists then you are wrong if you're
very biologist then you could sink about
an experiment for example you can start
cutting short pieces from DNA and when
you cut a piece and the cells start of
suddenly lost ability to replicate it
means that probably you cut out the
original application but if you are a
computer scientist you should just
refuse solving this problem it is an
ill-defined computational problem so how
can we turn this ill-defined
computational problem into something
that makes sense
let's try to ask a question how does the
cell know to begin replication in short
or EC region zoom must be must be some
hidden messages in the genome that tell
the cell replicates start replication
right here what are these hidden
messages so but let's first try to
formulate the problem right so the right
formulation will be the hidden message
problem in this case input is a string
text representing replication origin and
output is a hidden message in the text
is this problem clear if you fill this
problem clear please raise your hands 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
this problem is absolutely unclear it is
equally poorly defined is the first
problem I showed you indeed Shawn is not
happy again because what is the hidden
message have I described it no so for a
computer scientist there is no even
starting point to address this problem
but let's go two centuries back and
let's see how somebody in a somewhat
similar situation try to solve a similar
problem
we go to the Goldbach short story by
Edgar and poor and in this story is a
hero whose name was lagron try to decode
the message left by pirates and his hope
was that when he decode the message he
will be able to find the pirate treasure
so he was quite motivated the only thing
he saw is this text how would you tell
of what is written what is coded in this
text what Legrand noticed that the
combination of three symbols semicolon
for na appears surprisingly frequently
in this text does it suggest an idea on
what's written in the message here's a
hint the message is in English and
here's another hint there is the most
frequent word in English and that's why
he was able to substitute semicolon for
a for T G th e and this message started
to make sense and if you have time you
can complete decoding now if the our
original hidden message problem was
clearly ill-defined
let's now try to redefine it so it would
make sense even for computer scientists
how would we would redefine it well for
various biological signals certain words
appear surprisingly frequently in the
text for example at this slide a a TD T
appears surprisingly frequently in a
short text it's unlikely that it would
happen by chance and then the family our
first real Rosalind problem frequent
words problem is I give you a string and
an integer K and you need to find all
most frequent k-mers in texts which mean
all most frequent strings of length K in
the text does the problem cleaner
let's ask Shawn
he feels better but he is still not
clear because he doesn't know what
exactly the most frequent word means I
said he is a little bit peaky today
because it's easy to define who were the
most frequent word means a k-mer
streamed of lansky a k-mer partner is
the most frequent word in a text if no
other Kaymer is more frequent than
Parton and now even Shawn is satisfied
and I wanted to to thank Shawn for great
help with his development of this
lecture now the Sun is satisfied but we
should ask biologists whether this
problem actually makes sense
remember by informatics is about
connecting computational and
experimental ideas and if we check with
biologists the tosu looks that they're
quite satisfied with this problem indeed
replication is performed by DNA
polymerase but to initiate replication
DNA polymerase needs a protein called
DNA a DNA binds too short typically just
nine nucleotide segments within the
replication origin that is known as DNA
a box a DNA box is actually hidden
message that we are looking for and DNA
box essentially tells to DNA protein
bind right here a DNA protein wants to
see multiply dnaa boxes to bind
efficiently so it looks like we brought
computational people and biologists on
the same page and we are now ready to
try to solve this problem and since it's
the first problem at rosalind the expect
wide variety of different outer is
proposed by you the simplest out that it
is this one start from the first Kaymer
in the text slide it through the text
and see how many identical k-mers are
present in the text how much time it
takes it takes time roughly equal to
text multiplied by K but you need to do
it
every camera in CT extends roughly text
of them so overall running time of your
algorithms is very naive algorithm is
text square time k if text is 1 million
you may have problems but in our case
text is typically small the average
length of replication origin is just 500
maybe 700 nucleotide in this course we
will focus and we will soon learn much
more sophisticated algorithm well for
example some of you may be amazed that
the same task can be done incredibly
fast and we will cover this algorithm in
the class